tim you're a wonderful fellow it is
go ahead i was just gonna wrap it up
someone needs to i mean it's
it seemed like um it's a lot of pressure
this is our last interview
on this particular show so what they've
been so many versions of
shows right that whatever you know you
shouldn't feel any pressure
but this is the last like i read the i
read
and we haven't even talked about this um
what did the doctors say what do you
have and how long are they good
let's get that rumor started uh they
said it's just too much talent
and yeah actually it is
destroying my immune system i have so
much talent right and uh they said
you've got to just stop for a while
i know it hurts for me to be so close to
it trust me you know i mean like i can
feel it
yeah yeah you know when i first read you
and you know this because i called you
because i read the when i read that this
version of this show is ending right um
i have to say because my you know we've
been friends for a long time and so when
i read it
my my i thought immediately as soon as i
saw it i thought
what does this mean for me
and then but then right i thought oh and
andy
and then and then
i thought i should call conan yeah um
several weeks later i heard from you
because no yeah
but whatever you will always be in some
version doing something
with each other romantic i feel like
before i go
i should say something of value about
how much this show and and uh this
friendship and we met on this show it's
true
yeah no you you came on the show and we
you came on the show and we became
friendly and i knew right away this is a
guy
who'll be a friend of mine and interrupt
me in my
personal life and my professional life
never let me finish a sentence
this is a guy who can do that for me the
rest of my life i think i said something
you know that bit we did we should get
together and actually we talked about
this
bit idea and i remember saying we should
get together and and um
and actually do that and you said you
know or we could just get together and
go
have a dinner and drinks or something
and not do the bit and not do the bit
which crushed my show business dreams
but
um because i think the bit could have
been big but uh
but i really appreciated it and then uh
it was just sort of like yeah give me
your number give me a week uh we text
exchange numbers boom boom boom done
you know a lot of times in show business
somebody says hey we should have dinner
then the next thing i know is i have
someone's assistant reach out to my
agent who reaches out to me and then
i never see that person well i can't
because i'm not interested my assistant
doesn't do anything i ask her to do
okay to be fair you would have screwed
that up if i had said can you call tim
oliphant you'd have screwed it up
that's not true it is true you'd have
called him and set up a dinner with you
and tim
oh yeah in fact
[Laughter]
yeah no he's really cool yeah yeah
listen whatever that that
you know listen i know you've you've
told me about the problems
yes with sona what
they're legendary he said you're aware
of them
and then it doesn't matter yeah doesn't
matter anymore
i don't know what he's talking about
okay but but you'll
you know this over the years i don't
know how many years it's been
we don't we don't we don't ever like i
never get like oh
conan wants to have dinner at this
restaurant from
he just handles it all on his on his own
yeah that's me that's
i see that as a sign of this is by the
way we can stop the cameras
oh they ran out of tape tim they ran out
of tape about 40 minutes ago
frank how are we doing by the way do we
i tried
i had it we have it and we feel like we
have
something do we we do we want to no
we've got it hear more about your
teacher that you haven't seen
i'm ending this we have it in spades
ruth weisberg
first of all is wonderful woman
wonderful work uh we have to turn the
theater back over
and still to the people that own it um
we uh there's there's a high school
graduation coming in
yeah we have to get out of here but
listen you have been a terrific
you're a terrific guest you are a very
good friend
and whatever i do next you'll be a part
of it i promise you even if you don't
want to be
oh that's fantastic but yeah yeah it'll
be great so is there money involved
no be very no money involved just
friendship and loyalty and
not even friendship hey what thank you
so much for coming you know what
timothy oliphant there's no one else
like you and we thank the good lord
every day
you guys are the best you're the best